now Michael it's not just us here in
this room that please your back everyone
is so happy you're back you must have
seen this thing that goes tomorrow every
year this does them all for God you only
have one Christmas album you notice I
don't find that as funny as everybody
else whole friends I have literally send
me like the thing that I have and send
me it and go promise you I get it
and I think I hate you know I mean yeah
god it's a very good Christmas album
yeah but I mean now there are people
that really think that I live in a cave
there really are but this this is a mad
statistic and I can't I mean your
Christmas album has been the number one
album every Christmas in Australia since
2011
what do you mean it makes no sense do
people lose it like if you've got it why
is it number one again the next year
what multiple copies well do you know
how how smart and wonderful the
Australian what's great is that they
they did stream it they download it they
buy it it makes a good coaster it's
crazy because you think Australia I mean
when you don't they it's Christmas is so
huge there and it's so different
obviously but yeah I am so so thankful
for the money I know what I'm getting
this year my cave Zak of Australian
dollars
[Music]
you